let's get latest on that and of course
reaction uh to that interview with uh
dmitry peskov yesterday uh we're joined
once again by the ukrainian ambassador
to the uk vadim prischneichel uh
lovely to have you back on the program
ambani's ambassador um i i don't know if
you watched i suspect you will have been
briefed at the very least as to the
contents of that discussion uh with
dimitri peskov yesterday what did you
make of it
nothing unexpected that's the first
appearance on a wider tv audience in the
world stage but the message isn't the
same
we have to defend ourselves by killing
and coming to ukraine
at least he recognized that they're
losing soldiers left and right
that was the one concession that was
made before we go on i just i just
for our viewers and for you we put you
know some well-established well-felt
fleshed-out evidence of war crimes being
committed uh to uh mr peskov yesterday
this is what he had to say and i think
it's worth having a listen
we deny that russian military
can have something in common with these
atrocities and with dead bodies that
were shown on the streets of butcher
it's not a conspiracy actually it's a
bold fake
i mean it's not it's it's not just it's
not just that which is referring away a
well-staged insinuation murdered
civilians he's referring to them as as
poor people i mean it is all accusations
of russian involvement in war crimes and
when you have a position such as that i
mean how is it possible for the west to
respond i believe your president made it
very clear that they can join the
international investigation effort
which mr biscov denied
just because they don't recognize they
can come with anybody else and check it
if he has stomach so you know to face
these people he can come to butcher
himself itself and and check it and see
it and the problem is the butcher is not
the only place we are uncovering more
and more russian atrocities as soon as
we're
liberating these small small towns in a
way can we give me some examples what
what have ukrainian forces found there
has been an ebb and flow of course so
control of territory during this
conflict as the russians have withdrawn
and ukraine have moved in give me some
examples of that which has been found
very very small in significant town of
baradian because this is a tight tiny
tiny one 23 dead bodies in just in one
block of flats and we'll see more and
more you can imagine what would happen
when we liberate the marijuana which you
mentioned we've been bombarded bombarded
over the months already
so that's will be a very aggressive
picture you are of course here as your
your government's representative but
you're also a ukrainian yourself how
does it make you feel when you look at
pictures that the likes of which we've
seen from inside inside bridge and
elsewhere even for us and ukrainians
when some many many difficult tragic
experiences ourselves starting with with
the borders and the famines and you know
chernobyl and everything now coming to
this we just don't have enough time
because they're always coming mostly
russians each and every time we have a
chance to do our own development our own
choice and the the the the empire is
coming back you know this
colonial expectation that they have we
have to be subdued at any cost this is
what's troubling us
there are however an increasing number
of voices including amongst them the
conservative mp uh tobacco with chairman
of the defense select committee was on
the program this morning calling for
nato to do much much more we had that
meeting yesterday there will be heavier
armaments coming i mean i'm sure you're
warmly welcoming that but but you want
more
we need more and we need to change what
we are doing together with nato we've
been discussing it months ago and months
ago with that sooner or later we will
have to come to the conclusions really
radical conclusions for example we have
to unblock the black sea russians are
blocking sea for us that's our own sea
we need it for humanitarian assistance
to come in ukraine and we actually have
it to you know to allow ukrainian
experts mostly grains to go out we are
responsible for a significant chunk of
food security around the globe many
nations in africa asia are fed because
of ukrainian grain and this grain is
stuck in our silos can can be exported
can be sent anywhere
when you talk then about about doing
something about the black sea about
doing something about odessa and so on
let's be specific about it what are you
referring to nato ships in their again
zone as clear as that nato ships in the
black sea they are welcome in our sea
and there are members of nato at least
three of them members of nato within the
basin of the turkey romania and bulgaria
so they're already there it's not a big
deal we need to have somebody to
reinforce the effort yes to come and
they invited to address all the way in
i i do want to talk about war crimes but
in a slightly in a slightly broader
sense that there have now been
accusations of allegations of war crimes
being committed by ukrainian forces
skype
verified footage an injured person in
your russian uniform shot at multiple
times whilst lying on the ground you may
not know about the specific incident i
just wonder what your view is
when the guns are put down and when the
violence has come to an end what is the
ukrainian commitment to investigating
itself we're making it very clear to all
our soldiers that's the drastic limits
the military are fighting there are some
limits and each and every incident will
will be investigated on a separate note
we are talking about civilians and
russians are killing raping
just our civilian people there are
differences all about all of us hated
the war as as it is when people are
killing each other but there is a
difference when you kill and then shoot
at this at the military when you're
fighting and when you killed innocent
civilians just because you
you know these people you've seen the
probably pictures they come in and
armored vehicles with bags of
preservatives
and condoms just seriously where are
they coming from and where they're
coming to and they're stealing
everything you've seen this the stuff
they're stealing i don't know pants and
then casseroles and just just things but
you understand the significance of why
i'm saying it because vladimir putin can
have documentary evidence of one single
ukrainian war crime that will be
trumpeted as an excuse for anything that
he does in and around your country i can
imagine that some soldiers could go all
the way if they see that the
the civilians have been killed away but
we made it clear to every one of them
that this is this is the
limit to anything and we will instigate
each hnn case
what do you make of the of the criticism
that's coming for vladimir putin from
from inside russia at the moment
financial times reporting today that
russell has become the first russian
group to call for investigations into
war crimes it is a significant moment of
course
we should note that rousseau's bosses is
dutch it's not russian himself but
but it is a significant moment isn't it
but what we've been expecting for quite
a long time that those especially those
businesses which are connected to the
west they're so interlinked with the
rest of the of the economy around the
globe they will understand the
consequences for them and especially
those ones which have the international
capital and international leadership
within the company these
entities they do understand that that's
that they will be entered for their
business at least and also they have
some consciousness
ambassador just before we go um we spoke
not that long ago within the past couple
of weeks given what you've seen since
since the last time we've talked are you
do you have any more confidence or any
less confidence that there will be an
end to the violence anytime soon we're
making this we're trying to build up
very very uneasy very very difficult
compromise and so many ukrainians are
not happy with with attempts of the
government you know to find some ground
with russia people in most of the kids
don't even understand how can we sit at
the table with those ones who are just
killing each and every day our people
but that's the nature of anywhere they
will come have to come to ant and we
will ambassador great to have you in the
studio again thanks very much